[MUSIC RAII & WHITNEY KEATON,
"NO WORRIES (STEP CLAP)"]
RAII: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: The
first thing I wanted
to ask you guys is let's
just talk about your life
and how you came together.
RAII: I went to college at
the University of Illinois
in Champaign-Urbana, and that
happens to be where she's from.
That's her hometown.
And at the end of
my freshman year
I was asked to join a
gospel recording group,
and she was a member
of that group.
So that's how we met.
We met through music.
There wasn't the
greatest introduction,
because I felt that she was not
the nicest person when I first
met her.
She just didn't talk to me.
RYAN LOREN: Why is that?
RAII: OK, so check it out.
I'm the new guy--
WHITNEY KEATON: So check it out.
RAII: Check it out.
RYAN LOREN: Oh,
I'll check it out.
RAII: I'm the new guy
in the group, right?
So I'm expecting everybody
to at least greet me.
I met everybody at the
album release party
from their previous project.
I'm expecting the new
members to be like, oh, hey.
Nice to meet you.
Welcome.
Or something.
And she's walking around and she
ain't giving me no eye contact.
She ain't giving me no nothing.
So I'm like, she is mean.
And that's what
I thought of her.
So it was not love at
first sight, unfortunately.
But yeah.
WHITNEY KEATON: I
didn't really talk much.
I just didn't really
talk much period.
It wasn't me being mean.
I wasn't being mean.
RYAN LOREN: Well, clearly
we found that out.
RAII: Well, so then once
we got passed that--
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
RAII: Right.
We realized we liked a
lot of the same artists,
and even on some of the
performances and rehearsals
and stuff like that we, would
sing on the bus on the way
to the different places the same
songs, the same artists, all
the way to, like, the last
seconds when it's fading out,
and nobody really
knows that part--
WHITNEY KEATON: I'm like,
oh, you know that part, too?
RAII: --unless you really
listen to that artist.
And so that's how we bonded.
Like, it was a really
strong and organic and real.
And we became
really good friends
before we even started dating.
WHITNEY KEATON: And I starting
singing background for him
in college.
RYAN LOREN: Really?
WHITNEY KEATON: He would do
performances, and I would be--
I--
RAII: She was my lead singer.
WHITNEY KEATON: I was the
lead background singer.
RAII: I mean, she really was.
WHITNEY KEATON: I
would teach the parts,
and, you know, he
would be comfortable
with me working with
the singers separately.
So we would perform together
and work with each other.
RYAN LOREN: So name a
couple of the artists
that you guys liked in common.
WHITNEY KEATON: Brandy.
RAII: Brandy was the artist
that we bonded over the most,
I think.
WHITNEY KEATON: Yeah.
Yeah.
RYAN LOREN: All right.
Any particular songs?
WHITNEY KEATON: The
whole "Full Moon" album.
RAII: Right.
The whole "Full Moon."
WHITNEY KEATON: The
whole "Full Moon" album.
RYAN LOREN: All right.
I think let's just fast
forward to Alicia Keys.
RAII: OK.
RYAN LOREN: So you guys
toured with Alicia Keys
as her background singers.
You were there first,
if I'm not mistaken?
WHITNEY KEATON: Yes.
I just made six
years in October.
RYAN LOREN: And then
you brought RAII?
WHITNEY KEATON: He
just started in 2012.
RYAN LOREN: All right.
I just want to hear what
you feel that experience
brought you guys.
RAII: We were-- our
first professional gig
together was Estelle, and we
performed background for her.
So that gave us an
opportunity to work together
on a large platform.
It taught us how to trust
each other musically.
It taught us how to
listen more keenly.
And then we took that and
took it with us to Alicia.
And we learned how to
do this thing for real.
What it takes on and off stage.
It's not just having
a great voice.
It's about having a great
energy and a great spirit.
And I think--
WHITNEY KEATON:
That's the biggest.
RAII: More than anything.
WHITNEY KEATON: That's the
biggest beyond the talent.
Like, your personality,
how you communicate,
and how you work with each
other, how you treat people.
Because on tour, Alicia's
such a huge artist
she has so many different
types of performances,
and so we could be in
sound check rehearsing
for another event or--
it's always changing.
There are always different
renditions of the same song.
We have so many
different endings
of "Fallen," so many
for "If I Ain't Got You."
We have a Spanish version
of "If I Ain't Got You."
There's so many
different things,
and so with us,
it's not just about
are you capable of singing it,
because, well, we have the job.
So obviously she trusts
us in that department.
Since I'm the lead
background vocalist,
I arrange the parts
for tour, so when
there's something
changing, me and him
have to get together and arrange
new parts so that it's not
the same as the album
or it's not the same
as what we're doing on tour.
So we have to humble ourselves.
He has to take
that position like,
she knows what Alicia
wants so let me let her.
Even if I disagree with
the way she's doing it,
I have to listen to her.
And then when he
suggests something,
I have to humble myself even
though I've been there longer.
I have to say, well, OK.
That's a good idea.
OK, we'll do that.
We can do that.
Like, that's good.
So we have to do that
before we can even sing.
You have to be able to
create, arrange, and get
what you-- you have
to be on the same page
with what you're
going to present,
because a lot of the
times, before she comes
into the rehearsal,
the musical director
is there to help arrange
the music and do things.
And we have to get
something to present to her
to see if she even likes it
before we can even perform it.
So when she's there we have
to, even though we probably
just made it up and just started
singing it 15 seconds ago--
RAII: She can't know that.
WHITNEY KEATON: We have
to come in performing
as this is what we're going
to do for Letterman tonight.
And, you know, she'll
come in and she'll listen.
All right, that's cool.
Guitar, can you
give me an E flat?
OK.
And then she'll
start rearranging it.
And so then it
changes again, and we
have to still sing it as if
this is show time right here.
So we've learned to
catch onto things so fast
and learning how to
work in a moment.
I'm constantly having my
BlackBerry out recording stuff,
because stuff changes so fast.
I might have to listen
to it right before.
And here's Alicia
Keys, and I'm like,
let me listen to my
BlackBerry real quick.
And let me make sure
this is the right ending.
I'm not doing ending
B or ending C. We're
doing ending D for tonight.
So just working together
before we even--
RYAN LOREN: The D-th ending.
WHITNEY KEATON: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, so we have to
be on the same page
before the vocals
even come, really.
RYAN LOREN: What's
next for you guys?
I know you just
finished the tour,
and now you're ready
to have some space.
WHITNEY KEATON: Yes.
We have time to, first,
focus more on our marriage.
RAII: Yes.
WHITNEY KEATON: On each other.
WHITNEY KEATON: Because
stage is an extension of--
RAII: Home.
WHITNEY KEATON: --home.
So we can't jump
right into career
and performing and
planning all of that
if, again, we are
not on the same page.
It just doesn't work.
We don't want to be this
is who we are at home.
And then on stage we're kind
of trying to fake this persona.
We want it to be
authentic as possible,
and it only helps us mentally.
That's just too much work
to be trying to fake.
It's just too much work.
So we have time to
focus on each other,
and to talk to
family more, spend
time with friends
and family, and also
to be in the studio to
finish our project called
"A Time for Everything."
RAII: It's a joint
project, and it features
my wife Whitney Keaton--
WHITNEY KEATON: And
my husband RAII.
RAII: Which is her
stage name, by the way.
WHITNEY KEATON: Right.
My stage name is Whitney Keaton,
but legally I am Mrs. Smith.
RAII: Thank you.
I worked hard for
that, by the way.
And the project, some of
the songs feature her.
Some of the songs
feature myself.
feature us together.
It is a conversation
between a man and a woman,
and it's a relationship roadmap.
Someone called it that.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I really do appreciate that.
I like that you all liked it.
And "A Time for Everything"
is the name of it.
And there's a time for different
things in a relationship.
WHITNEY KEATON: And
those different things
are the titles of each song.
So each song is the journey.
RAII: Yep.
We're going to
present "No Worries,"
and that is a song that
came at a really-- a moment
in our lives where we had
to think to ourselves, we
gonna get through this.
WHITNEY KEATON: We were
unemployed for seven months.
RAII: We were unemployed
for seven months,
and this is without unemployment
coming in at the time.
And it was unexpected as well.
WHITNEY KEATON: In New York.
RAII: In New York
City, so you all
already know what that means.
But I was in the living
room working on some music,
and my wife comes in with tears
in her eyes singing, [SINGING]
no worries.
We'll get through it all.
WHITNEY KEATON: That's
the first thing that came.
It was just that.
RAII: And I said-- I said, what?
And she just kept singing it.
And we just started
dancing and crying
and it was like the song
really meant something to us.
It really helped us
through that time.
So when we sing it, I
remember that moment.
And then I look at where
we've gone since then,
being on the world
tour and going
to all these different places
that you read about when
you're in school, right?
It's true.
You get through it all.
As long as you
believe, as long as you
can see yourself getting through
it, you can get through it.
And so this project
is all of that.
Ups and downs.
You know, it's some
love songs on there,
because we are in love
and we do love love,
but it's some real
songs that's talking
about some hurtful stuff, too.
And I feel like
that's a conversation
that we need to have as
adults to not just be
so surface with it.
It's not always
going to be roses.
There are going to be some
issues and challenges--
WHITNEY KEATON: Where you have
to be honest with yourself--
RAII: You have to be honest.
WHITNEY KEATON:
To be vulnerable.
To communicate.
RAII: You got to communicate.
WHITNEY KEATON: Right?
RAII: You got to
compromise, you know.
And we talk about all of that.
WHITNEY KEATON:
Sometimes you have to let
some things go in
order to move forward.
Sometimes you just
gotta try and stop
trying to move forward with the
mindset of what used to happen.
You have to just--
RAII: Sometimes you got to be
willing to get to know somebody
for who they are and not for
what you want them to be.
These are all the titles
of the songs, by the way.
WHITNEY KEATON: By the way.
[LAUGHTER]
RAII: And God willing we'll be
able to put this project out
this year.
Hopefully we'll have
single out soon.
"No Worries," hopefully.
WHITNEY KEATON: Yes.
RAII: And we would definitely
appreciate your support.
WHITNEY KEATON: And
more performances.
RAII: More performances indeed.
WHITNEY KEATON: More
performances, more concerts.
We are looking to
expand, Atlanta, DC, LA.
We want to do more,
because we have--
we've done a few shows in New
York, but we need to build.
We were able to fly everywhere
with Alicia on her dime,
but now we got to
invest in ourselves.
Now we got to put
the money for us.
RYAN LOREN: Well, let
me be one of the first,
maybe, to say that it's an
investment well worth it.
RAII: Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: And thanks
again for being here,
and we wish you well for the
rest of this year and beyond.
WHITNEY KEATON: Yes.
RAII: Thank you, Ryan.
RYAN LOREN: All right.
[APPLAUSE]